there is a stranger who comes to this  village from the sea he comes in the  winter when people are hungry brings  fish comes on the king tide that was  last night took I believe that an enemy  is coming from far away I'm looking for  warriors this stranger others like him  I'm building an alliance to defend us  it's very important that I see this man  Barry Allen Bruce Wayne you said that  like it explains why there's a total  stranger sitting in the dark in my  second favorite chair  he said he'll fight with us or less  probably more or less he said no he said  no look man I don't know who you are but  whoever you're looking for  so you're fast that feels like an  oversimplification I'm putting together  a team people with special abilities see  I believe enemies are coming stop right  there  I'm in you are just like that yeah I  need friends right guys heat this  I heard about you didn't think you were  real  I'm realise useful  Arthur curry here you can talk to fish